我之所以今天这么做是第一因为我有这个本事，
我有这个能力，
我可以这么做。
第二，
我之所以今天这么做，
是因为我对你有感情，
我愿意支持你，
帮助你，
至于说将来你会不会感恩我，
这件事情别想，
我是本来是想在领证之前带给你看看，
但现在我们也领证了，
我觉得我现在比较坚定这个选择和正确的。
我是一个老师，
在三线城市，
是在32岁，
有编制，
我的学历是研究生，
可能长相和颜值身材是中等中上一点点吧，
我有一套首付的房子贷款了。
我的对象我们是同城的，
他比我大四岁，
他的外貌上来说可能要差一点点，
他幺七五两百斤左右，
有点胖，
学历是专科，
工作是属于国家的科研事业单位，
我收入大概12左右，
他估计20多，
他有一段短暂的婚史，
因为他长期出差，
两人性格不合，
然比方提出分手，
再跟我相亲，
我们俩认识，
所以刚开始我父母，
特别是我爸爸不太接受，
但是呢，
实际上在跟他相处的过程当中，
我被他这个人所打动，
他这个人的性格很好，
很善良，
很贴心，
然后我发现他不仅对我这样，
对他周围的人，
对他的父母都是如此，
最开始我担心他会不会是伪装的呀，
但经过我一年。
说两年的考察，
我觉得他的性格本色是很样的，
我们俩也在前几天领了证，
他的父母对我也比较的认可，
彩礼给了18.8，
以及在这七间，
他爸爸给了1万，
妈妈给了1万，
姥爷这些也都有。
其实从这方面来说，
我觉得他还是比较重视我的，
我们俩一年准备结婚，
装修新房，
30万的装修的钱，
他妈妈把钱直接打给了我，
全权交给我们俩处理，
他妈妈全程不参与，
要尊重我。
他的父母也是同一个单位的，
所以他们的工作、
家庭总体来说是很好，
父母能够给予经济上面的支持是没有太大问题了。
今天我主要想问的应该就是原生家庭，
我的父母就是普通家庭打工，
我们都是农村出来的，
我的父母都是五十四、
五十六岁，
现在他们常年也就是一会儿做点这个，
一会儿做点那个，
反正也把我和我弟供出来了。
我父母对我来说，
我觉得算普通家庭当中能托取我的，
因为我们从农村家庭出来，
他能够支持我读研究生，
读大学，
虽然经济上可能没怎么支持，
因为在大学和读研期间，
其实生活费和学费我都是自理的，
都是我通过做家教自己上减轻家。
给负担，
你说父母给了多少经济支持，
可能并没有太多，
但是我觉得态度很重要，
所以我还是很感恩我的父母。
现在就面临一个问题，
就是我的母亲前几年生病，
生完病之后他的性格变化特别大，
我妈打麻将欠了2万左右，
我父母的工资没有什么固定收入，
我现在跟我老公结婚之后，
我不知道该如何对待我的父母，
但他的钱和固定的洋恒来打麻将欠的钱不要替他还，
有一次就有二次，
有二次就有三次，
这是无底洞。
所以从一开始就要建立边界感，
打麻将欠的钱我一分都不会替你还，
别人骂你，
别人说你女儿为什么不替你还债，
我能扛得住别人的道德指责，
我就是不会替他们还赌债，
但是我可以给你买米买油买面买盐买醋买酱油，
我保证你们饿死，
但是你想让我还什么？
打麻将欠3万，
到时候再跟别人推台酒欠5万，
我一分都没有好，
因为我跟我的老公结婚之后，
可能我和我老公工作算比较好，
也就是有稳定收入吧，
比起我的父母，
我不知道该如何对他们好，
我刚才不是说了吗？
隔三差五的买块牛肉，
隔三差五的买只鸡买只鸭，
不都是对他们好吗？
家里水果，
苹果、
橙子，
隔三差五的我给。
不买呀，
但你说你打牌欠钱这个事儿别来沾边啊，
一点都不用沾边儿啊。
在年前出现了这么一个事儿，
我首付买了房子，
当时我爸妈说的是支持我10万，
在前几天我爸说这个10万让我自己还，
所以我就突然难以接受，
但是呢，
我也快速的能够理解他们，
我也把那10万块钱还了，
我和我老公本来准备说给他们俩都买养老保险，
我特别担心我对我原生家庭付出过多，
我还有个弟弟，
我弟弟现在高二，
每天晚上回家住我这儿，
生活费由我爸妈负责，
其他的一些开支都在我这，
学习上也都是我管理，
所以我现在不太清楚应该怎么去跟我的原生家庭相处，
我担心伏地魔，
但是我担心他没有人情味，
在你的能力范围之内，
千万不要动用你老公的钱，
比如说你想给你爸妈买养老保险，
那你有这个本事买嘛，
如果你有这个本事买，
那在你老公同意的情况下，
我认为是可以买的，
因为这个相当于是什么呢？
一锤子买卖，
一次性买了多少养老保险的话，
将来他们一个月有800也好，
有500也好，
够吃。
比如说我爸妈在农村的话，
他俩加起来一个月800块钱够吃了，
好的，
我跟我老公很早没结婚之前就说过这个事儿，
是我老公的爸爸主动提出说要买，
但是我一直还没给。
爸妈说，
因为我担心就是帮助太多，
他们提前就已经处于退休状态，
所以我一直还没告诉他们我们的打算。
其实这个事儿呢，
解放的是你，
最终帮的是你自己，
如果你有这么明事理的公公，
又有这么好的老公，
他们提出了这个事儿的话，
其实最终帮衬的是你，
其实公公是有远见的，
意思就是说现在趁年轻，
你们一把给他们养老买好了之后，
将来就解决很多事儿了，
将来就没必要说老给他们生活费了，
没必要老惦记他们了。
长远来看的话，
解放的是你，
因为你弟弟年纪小嘛，
如果说你弟弟将来成长为一个有责任有担当的这样一个男性角色的话，
可能你弟弟也就承担了你爸爸妈妈的养老这方面的责任了啊，
但现在不还是未知数嘛，
因为我和我弟年纪差距很大，
我估计以后我父母的养老多半我和我老公得多操心，
所以我也没太多指望我弟怎么样，
我父母所以我想着我和我老公会给他们买，
但是我弟现在高二以后面临着读大学以及各种的花销，
我就特别担心我自己在这个当中处理不好啊，
我觉得这个事情还是量力而行，
别图回报，
别想着他以后会感恩。
我之所以今天这么做是第一，
因为我有这个本事，
我有这个能力，
我可以这么做。
第二，
我之所以今天这么做，
是因为我对你有感情，
我愿意支持你，
帮助你，
至于说将来你会不会感恩我这件事情别想，
首先是量力而行，
比如说他想买一个1000块钱的鞋子，
直接佛学200块很好穿了，
我没有这个本事，
比如说他想买一个2万块钱的电脑，
直接否决，
我没有这个本事，
我给你买个3000的电脑，
够用了就得了。
比如说他想买一个苹果手机，
直接否决，
我没有这个本事，
我给你买一个小米的手机，
够用了得了，
在我的能力范围之内，
我给你做到了，
你和你的同龄人，
同班同学，
不至于说你被别人甩十条街八条街，
别人都有手机你没有，
别人都有电脑你没有，
不至于那样，
我就已经再是我自己了。
好的，
菲菲姐，
我还有个问题，
以后我如果跟我老公生娃的话，
可能都得他的父母帮我又出钱又出力，
我有的时候就在想，
这样是不是不太好，
如果这个想法就是太奇怪了啊，
如果说公公婆婆有这个钱，
有这个力愿意出力，
那就勇敢承认，
我就是命好，
我就是运气好，
我就是有这个福气，
我的孩子也就是命好，
我的孩子有这个福气，
勇敢的承认且接纳，
坦然的接纳，
而不要命吧，
不要一方面人家出了钱案出的力命。
所以又要人家对尊重，
又要人家对你重视，
千万别搞这一出。
我原来她那个小舍得有一个女的，
就是她嫁的老公吧，
老公不太上进，
老公不太有本事，
但是公公婆婆贼有钱，
公公婆婆差百万上千万的都有钱，
给他们买房子，
给他们什么都婆支持，
孩子想学什么都行。
这个女的就特别拧巴，
一方面想要公公婆婆出钱，
另方面又想要公公婆婆瞧得起她尊重她，
就纯扯她一就要知道啊，
公公婆婆如果出钱出力的话，
就别想着公公婆婆还得尊重你，
就得瞧得起你，
你就得什么抱大腿，
就有抱大腿的修养，
就得时常挂在嘴边感谢公公婆婆，
我怎么命这么好，
我怎么找这么好的公公婆婆，
我的孩子怎么命这么好，
怎么有那么好的爷爷奶奶，
爷爷奶奶给我孩子衣食住行，
从小大大什么事儿都包了，
可太有福气了，
就得这么过日子。
好的，
接纳我有福气，
接纳我的孩子有福气，
就得抱大腿，
抱大腿就得有抱大腿的姿势，
别想着人家又给钱又给力，
还尊重你，
他还在乎你没有那么来的啊。
好的，
菲菲姐，
也就是说我对我父母，
如果说我能帮助他把两个人的养老保险买好，
逢年过节发一点点钱买一点东西，
那很好了，
说的那就这样啊，
好，
再见，
真的，
有的时候人不能拧巴，
一方面是吧，
物质上人家公公婆婆又出钱又出力的又拧巴了，
因为公公婆婆但凡是有能力有本事的公公婆婆。
他多少有点强势，
难免的，
我跟你讲，
我直播间有没有你公公婆婆又出钱又出力，
但他有点强势，
比如说孩子要读哪个小学了，
孩子要上私立了，
孩子要学什么才艺了，
出钱出力的公公婆婆她多少有点强势啊，
你得认这个，
因为他之所以能又出得起钱，
出得起力，
肯定是他在社会竞争上他拿到的结果的，
但凡是在社会竞争上能拿到结果的人，
他多少是有点魄力，
有点强势，
不然的话，
他拿不到这样的结果，
但然你要是遇到不出钱不出力还强势的公公婆婆的话，
可以断交啊，
可以少来往，
但是遇到出钱出力的公公婆婆，
人家强势人家该记得点赞关注哦。